hi everybody I'm Jimmy and this is
bright insight today we're going to do
part two of debunking the textbooks in
regards to the pyramids of Egypt does
anyone else find it really odd that the
textbooks never ever mentioned that the
Pyramids of Giza in Egypt just happened
to be located at the geographical center
of all land mass of planet Earth that's
right the east-west parallel across is
the most land and the north-south
Meridian that crosses the most land
intersect in two places on planet Earth
one is in the ocean the other just
happens to be at the location of the
Great Pyramid of Giza so I really doubt
that that's the coincidence am I the
only one that thinks that I mean come on
it just so happens that one of the last
surviving ancient wonders of the world
one of the largest and most mysterious
structures ever built just happen to be
located on the one exact spot on planet
earth that is completely unique and of
itself and it makes you wonder with all
the different theories about what the
pyramids were actually used for because
they weren't tombs anyone with
analytical mindset clearly see that they
were not tombs now I'm not saying that
the dynastic Egyptians didn't utilize
them as tombs what I am saying is that
whatever advanced civilization ruled
this earth prior to the global Cataclysm
that happened twelve thousand nine
hundred and eighty years ago give or
take five years as verified through core
ice samples from Antarctica as well as
Greenland and the second Cataclysm that
happened 1,400 years later approximately
eleven thousand six hundred years ago
were total reset buttons on humanity I'm
going to make a video on the global
Cataclysm and all the supporting
evidence of it because it's genuinely
conclusive and I highly recommend that
you look into the works of Graham
Hancock Randall Carlson John Anthony
West Robert Schoch Brien Foerster and
many others because together their works
clearly show overwhelming evidence that
that actually happened and clearly that
if mankind had advanced civilization at
that time as verified by gobekli tepe in
Turkey you can clearly see that there's
so much more to that history of ancient
civilization that we were ever told in
school and you know I also find it
really interesting that the textbooks
failed to mention the massive tunnel
system located in and under the Giza
Plateau surrounding the pyramids now
most people are familiar that yes there
were
tunnels built underneath the pyramid but
most people aren't aware that that was
dug over three stories down into solid
bedrock now just to clarify when I say
solid bedrock it is limestone bedrock
which is a four out of ten on the Mohs
scale of hardness so yes that could be
dug out with pickaxes but it would be
overwhelmingly difficult now I'm not
saying it didn't happen by people I'm
not saying that that wasn't dug out
however it's particularly interesting
how there's very little information out
there about the massive tunnel system or
these incredibly deep shafts seemingly
random dozens of them located throughout
the Giza Plateau and they range from
anywhere from 60 to 100 feet deep but
their actual depths are still unknown
because they're covered with thousands
of years of sand that of poured into
them I mean look these were perfectly
symmetrical squares ranging from ten by
ten and in some cases 15 by 15 and they
were cut perfectly out of solid
limestone bedrock now the precision of
all that is very interesting but what's
even more interesting is that these
vertical shafts also connect to
horizontal shafts that run randomly
throughout the Giza Plateau many of
which are allegedly not explored and
they don't know what's in them but yet
they're closed and blocked off to the
public as you can see from all these
cages located throughout now let me
mention that all of these pictures that
you see on this video are from Google
Images however most of them originated
from Brien Foerster check him out on
YouTube check out his website hidden
incre tours calm I can't wait to go on a
tour with him one day once I have the
money but literally these are things
that you would never know if you didn't
actually see his essentially homemade
videos where he takes you and walks you
around the Giza Plateau and you see all
these random shafts to just plummet
straight into the earth
now what would these tell is use for I
have no idea maybe just maybe these were
utilized to move water as in support of
some sort of power system I have no idea
maybe the pyramids were not a power
system what I do know is that whatever
their original purpose was we're far
more sophisticated than just a tomb
something else is very interesting that
you hardly hear anything about and is
certainly not mentioned in the textbooks
is that there was never any found in
these pyramids that's right now take for
example the picture on the left that's
of the 15 chapel most people are
completely unaware that it took years
restoration in order to remove the
incredible amount of soot that
accumulated from centuries of candles
and
churches that were utilized to
illuminate the structure obviously
before there was lightbulbs
now take this picture from Egypt that
seemed to show some sort of symbolism
for I would say electricity couldn't you
argue that that snake is symbolic of an
electrical current but if that's not
reason enough if you don't if you don't
buy into that look at the lotus flower
that it's connected to and how it seems
to have a cord connected to some sort of
box guys I'm not saying that this is a
light bulb it seems to be symbolic of
something very sophisticated that's all
I'm saying but when you think about the
implications that the pyramids of Egypt
don't have any such located in them
isn't that really odd so how do they
what do they use to illuminate how do
they see when they were building this if
the Sistine Chapel that was built
thousands of years after the pyramid had
tons of sidonis why don't the Egyptian
pyramids now there's so much information
that we don't know about the pyramids of
Egypt for example are you aware that
there's been two rooms discovered with
inside the Great Pyramid of Giza as
verify through the use of infrared
thermography and laser scanning and you
can see a picture of it here guys there
is so much that we still don't know
about the pyramids and now we're finding
that there's these other chambers
located in the we've never even seen
before and does anyone else find it
suspicious that the egyptian government
takes years to make a decision on
granting a permit for anyone to
investigate or research any of these
areas or these hidden chambers doesn't
anyone else find it completely odd that
they keep it shrouded in secrecy and
forbid anyone from looking into this
stuff yeah that's an indicator that
they're hiding something that's be
honest another little known fact that
many people are becoming aware of now
but still most people I've never heard
of is the fact that the pyramid the
Great Pyramid of Giza has eight sides
not four and the reason why this was
hidden and unknown for so many centuries
is because it's so subtle that it's only
visible at dusk and dawn during the
spring and fall equinoxes but as you can
see in these photographs it is there and
it's incredibly precise and it further
validates the incredible mathematical
formulas and equations that were
necessary in order to construct the
pyramids to have them be completely
symmetrical in the ways that they are
let me give you some more information
that supports that perhaps whoever built
the pyramids were in advanced
civilization for example are you aware
that approximately 30 percent
all Native American DNA originates from
Middle Eastern DNA this is something
that's only been discovered in the last
few years but if you don't believe me
I'm citing National Geographic and where
it gets even more interesting is that
they're finding DNA in South American
mummies that have Egyptian DNA or excuse
me Middle Eastern DNA I can't presume
that it was the Egyptians but it's
Middle Eastern DNA explain that
furthermore they've established that
mummies found in Egypt have contained
cocaine and nicotine guys cocaine and
nicotine originate from plants they're
located nowhere near their region of the
Middle East and hence come from South
America
could it be further evidence to suggest
that there was once an advanced
civilization on earth that was able to
travel between the continent I mean how
do you explain the incredible
similarities between the Incan culture
in South America as well as the
Egyptians whether it's the same
technology of trapezoid doors or whether
it's the step pyramids or whether it's
the gold-plated funeral mask utilized
for their mummies there are so many
other similarities that should be
mentioned as well guys there is so much
more information on this subject that
needs to be shared so look forward to
more videos to come anyways guys I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight like and
subscribe to help me spread the message
take care everybody